I have a very ambitious agenda to get
through in 20 minutes so we all know
that we're at a transition moment we all
sense that and basically we're moving
from a world that was defined by seeking
efficiency and repetition and now we're
in a world that is not only different
but it's the exact opposite game it's
defined by change in this world a fit B
because they kept doing the same thing
in this world a changes and bumps
everyone around them etc change
baguettes and accelerates change so we
are living at the tipping point between
two absolutely opposite systems and that
has huge implications for every aspect
of every person's life for every
organization for every country City and
so all we're trying to do in 20 minutes
is understand this and I have promised
you know that I will give you a little
bit about the roots of the shoka as an
example of entrepreneurial behavior then
we'll go to what is this change in the
strategic environment in dealing with it
there is something new called
collaborative entrepreneurship you say
the word entrepreneur you typically mean
one person who's upsetting everyone
around them well imagine 700 working
together worldwide this is very powerful
and it's a key part of the change that's
going on and then finally come around to
what does this mean for each of us
individually in all aspects of our lives
so let me let me begin with my when I
promised to do if you imagine for 19
year-olds who cannot afford a flight to
India picking up a car in Germany and
driving there with the roads being dirt
roads two-thirds of the way so that's
how we got to India and once there
the statistics of hundred-to-one
difference in average per capita income
suddenly became people you knew and
since if you have the slightest
entrepreneurial thrust the question then
is what are you going to do about it
well as you know pretty well sophomores
control absolutely nothing so leverage
becomes really important so what's the
most highly leveraged way of closing the
north-south gap which is another way of
speeding up the change process well
what's the most powerful force in the
world it's always regardless of time or
sector a big pattern change idea but
only if it's in the hands of a really
good entrepreneur it's that combination
that moves history all was and so we
said ok well what if we were able to
encourage enable more of the best
entrepreneurs the best ideas dealing
with the social issues get started and
succeed and weave together and become a
community that helps one another that
could make a really big difference so
that was really it's a very simple idea
and it turns out that it's it's a very
valid one so when we got started there
was no word social entrepreneur we had
to invent it which tells you just how
backward this field was so one of our
first challenges was how do you
introduce this idea is field and our
first really major success was
introducing over twenty odd years a
framework change we're now pretty much
people across the world think about I
could have a career in causing
significant change for the good and as
you all know there are there's almost a
panic my universities to now serve this
area Stanford was one of the first
so the power of this idea of you think
about it is really very simple if you
help a really powerful idea in an
entrepreneur get started they're not
going to stop
they will it'll just keep growing and
you're helping launch the institution
and they are role models you know if she
can do this well maybe I can do
something and it turns out the social
entrepreneurs in particular have another
very powerful impact they are not in
this to capture a market and dig a moat
the goal is to change the world for the
good and so how do you do that well
you're not going to go and deal with
every school or village or whatnot so
you have to make your idea as simple and
understandable and safe as possible
precisely so that thousands and
thousands of other people can say oh
that's a good idea we're going to make
that work for our community so the
structure of social entrepreneurship is
not just the entrepreneur in the
organization but there's a third
dimension which is it pretty invisible
to most scholars in act and and business
people because it's not in business
which is the movement and in doing that
you are also encouraging thousands and
thousands of local people to stand up
and be change makers and they become
role models and they recruit other
people so this is an invisible mechanism
that's really powerful it's moving as
towards the everyone a changemaker world
right so it's a really simple idea
interview a couple of quick examples
Mary Gordon is a Canadian Ashoka fellow
she was teaching a class in Toronto and
she saw that's very key entrepreneurs
you have to first give themselves
permission to see a problem and if
you're not a change maker the last thing
in the world you want to see is a
problem or an opportunity because what
do you you can't do anything about it
if you don't if you aren't a change
maker I'm so Mary gave herself
permission to see the problem that
children in her class when they saw if I
had to deal with another child who made
them uncomfortable all they could do is
respond with aggression which of course
invites aggression back and as that
pattern gets deeper and deeper the
future for those children gets bleaker
and bleaker and that school is just not
going to be a very attractive place so
she gave herself permission to change
the whole system not just her class so
she had to find something pretty simple
but I can tell you now that there are
two countries that have this is national
policy and Scotland which may or may not
become a country is also has also made
that decision now what did she do she
brings an infant two to four months old
to the class at the beginning of the
school year and asks for three hours a
month so this is 24 hours over eight
months and the infant wears a little
t-shirt the professor presides from a
green blanket mom is there and the first
grader so the third graders have to
figure out what is the professor saying
and then what is a professor of feeling
well this is very powerful and it works
children we are all genetically we're
social species and we know we've got to
figure that out so these kids are all
over this we're opening that door for
them this is not that complicated it
doesn't cost a lot it doesn't upset
people etc so this is one person who
gave herself permission who's playing a
very important role and I'm I didn't
choose this example by accident it plays
into the larger theme we're coming to
Joe via let some of you know her play
work she's right here in the Bay Area's
she's reintroducing play especially to
the city since your school city center
schools that have done away with it
so they have more memorizing time and
less conflict what's the idea well it
turns out that her methodology turns on
group play and group play is a good way
for kids to practice empathy so those
are two examples you can immediately see
how they fit together of 700 of the
3,000 Ashoka fellows focused on children
and young people and you won't be
surprised but when you move to this very
different world everyone has to have a
different set of skills and the
foundational skill is cognitive empathy
which is beyond I feel your pain which
elephants can do it's something you have
to learn we have Mara neurons we have
the cerebral cortex so everyone can do
this but if we don't consciously enable
children to do this how on earth are
they supposed to do it the world we're
in now in the world we're going into is
getting more and more complicated and so
what you have to do applying cognitive
en't it's complicated you have to
understand all the people around you
layers out further and further into the
future and not just in a couple of
contexts that are stable over a person's
life but now a kaleidoscope of all these
different contexts as the world changes
faster and faster well every year at the
level of cognitive empathy you have to
master is going up and if you don't
master it what happens well you're gonna
hurt people and you're going to disrupt
groups it used to be not so long ago
that you could be a perfectly successful
first person if you just knew the rules
and diligently followed them well the
central fact is that the rate of change
is going up exponentially since at least
1700 we can measure that and we've
gotten to the point that the rules don't
exist
they haven't been invented they're in
conflict they're changing and you just
can't be a good person by diligently
following the rules so we are
guaranteeing the marginalization of vast
numbers of children because we aren't
smart enough to realize that there's a
paradigm for education for growing up
that requires us well Mary is an Jill or
two people who show us how to do it okay
so now I'm going to come back to this
and use this thing this need for a
change a framework change when we get to
collaborative entrepreneurship if I want
to take a important detour to describe
the strategic environment change a
little more deeply everyone here is
already in this new world you wouldn't
be in this room if you weren't but most
people aren't and just being able to see
oh this is the new game that's what's
going on is really powerful in enabling
then people can figure out what they
need to do as a young person as a parent
as a leader of any institution any group
if you don't know the new game how can
you possibly play it so there's a huge
power in helping people to see it all
right so let me just quickly lay the
scene all through prehistory and up to
very recently the game was efficiency in
repetition that's what human
organizations were designed to do and we
learned how to have efficiency at bigger
and bigger scale and gained tremendous
wealth out of that so think the assembly
line or the law firm and how are these
organizations characterized you've got a
few people who choreograph everyone else
and what you want is everyone else to
have a specialty that they're really
good at and they practice and do a lot
and you want them to stay within those
walls and you know aphids be because
they keep doing the same thing and we
build up very complicated structures
with finer and finer stovepipes
universities are not exactly immune to
this problem and
well this doesn't work very well as you
go up that curve of exponential change
what is the environment like now well
each piece changes and bumps everyone
else so you have to constantly change
who you're working with if you're going
to do a good job now I'm serving in this
new environment so instead of stable the
Wald institutions now you have to have a
fluid no walls because you have to
constantly be putting together new
combinations of people and resources
from all over the world to be able to do
a good job of serving the opportunity
that's there today but will be different
tomorrow so you can't have walls so
fluid open is obvious you have to get
the best ideas anywhere in the world the
best inputs the best relationships the
best access so open so fluid open teams
of teams now this the word team is very
precise you don't have a team if one
person is telling it where else what to
do and a team everyone is the player and
in a world where everything is changing
and the game is contributing to change
and contributing to the constant
rearrangement that is associated with
that you better be a change maker
because people can't afford to have you
on their team if you aren't and this is
very stark and it's happening very
quickly one of the things that happens
when you go up an exponential curve what
took fifty years now is taking ten years
so Detroit in this country was the top
of our technology pride not to mention
hubris the big tail fins the whole thing
50 years ago and you know where it is
today they missed out they missed
entirely well that could happen to the
country or it could happen to any metro
area or to any ethnic group or any other
group if anyone misses this historic
turn they don't have a lot of time to
so everyone has to be a change maker
this is a shoka's goal now everyone a
change maker world helping people see it
helping everyone get there now this
phrase is very radical we mean everyone
everyone no mental reservations no not
including all those people they can't do
this they can if we structure society so
that they can kind of change maker
that's the most powerful thing you can
be so everyone really powerful everyone
having the gift that everyone in this
room has that being able to give at a
significant level to express love and
respect and significant action that is
what brings everyone all the prophets
and scientists tell us this health
longevity happiness well we have that
it's not right that other people don't
have it
so we're saying everyone has to master a
set of skills so that they are change
makers so they can really contribute and
play in this game and you have to
organize in ways that make that work so
what is the standard of success in this
new world for any group or any team of
teams what proportion of your people are
changemakers at what level of skill of
change making and how good a job are you
city country whatever it is doing and
helping people work together in this
fluid open way we're living right here
in this valley at an epicenter and you
can see how quickly things are moving in
that direction well it's gonna be much
faster in this once people see this then
it's going to be really quick and so
then there's huge leverage in helping
people over the awareness tipping
process and we think we're very very
close so that's a quick summary of this
change in the strategic environment so I
want to put in the final building block
in this
analysis before I come to what this
means for each of us and that is
collaborative entrepreneurship so I'm
going to use the example of now we have
to have everyone master the skills to be
a really good changemakers that's a
profound change you can't get everyone a
changemaker world unless you have and
everyone a changemaker population by
definition and so how do we do that well
you have to start with young children
and young people now you have to change
how you deal with the people who work
with you in the workplace as well but
because we have a short time I'm going
to focus only on young children and
briefly young people so every young
child must master cognitive empathy
thank you Mary Gordon and Joe Violette
and 700 others we know how to do that so
how do we get society to recognize that
we need to do that how many secondaries
how many elementary school principals in
this country or anywhere in the world
know they're failing if you have one
second grader who is not grasped
cognitive empathy and if all the kids
aren't practicing it isn't on their
agenda they are rated in terms of how
did you do on the test scores the old
information transfer game and you can't
have mayhem in the hallway ie rule enos
well that was a formula that worked when
you were trying to produce people who
would do the same thing all their life
you gave them the skills to be a baker
and the rules and they could be a baker
or a banker or lawyer or whatever it is
and that was efficient when you were in
the old efficiency and repetition model
it is absolutely dysfunctional at this
point so I mentioned any child that
doesn't master cognitive empathy will
hurt people and is God and forget the
other skills they have to have went to
play and has to be a change maker the
other skills are teamwork
a very different type of leadership
when everyone's a changemaker you have
to lead in a very different way in a
village enable and schwer can very
different process and then change making
itself for very complicated learned
skills now I have just summarized a new
paradigm for growing up an education
every child must master cognitive
empathy and every teenager better be
practicing change making the test of
success is what proportion of 21 year
olds know that they're changemakers
because they've already been changed
makers and they've actually mastered the
skills of 21 there are secondary
measures such as what proportion of the
elementary school principals are focused
on cognitive empathy and know what to do
what we think we can change that in the
next five or six years the framework
change so here's my last intellectual
building block we think there are three
levels of impact and it's really
important to differentiate them direct
service you do need individuals to go
out and dig wells and teach an
individual classroom and the measures
for that are what you would expect
pattern change is what entrepreneurs do
you need a completely different set of
measures so we don't talk about how many
people do the Ashoka fellows serve
directly we measure them instead as
follows so over half have changed
national policy within five years of
launch three quarters have changed the
pattern in their field at the national
level within five years of launch over
ninety percent have had independent
institutions copy their idea in those
five years all those measures have to do
with pattern change now framework change
is different again it's the most highly
leveraged and we are living at a moment
where a large part of the game is
framework change people have got to see
the new game and then see what the
implications are for them in all aspects
of their lives and then you have to
translate it for geographic areas and
subject matter areas like wellness or
law
so here we are we want to change the
paradigm for young children and also for
teenagers but let me just take young
children so how do we do this well you
can't do it by direct service in the
u.s. is one of the ten places we think
you got a tip if you're going to tip the
world right so there are 80,000
elementary schools we are not going to
deal with $80,000 entry schools that is
completely wrong thinking and pattern
change doesn't really do it how many
schools have picked up Mary's ideas or
it's coming into the South Bronx in
Seattle etc but it's only when you have
the framework change and parents are
asking and schools are wanting this that
we've really changed the picture so how
do we bring about that framework change
so we have got hundreds of entrepreneurs
working together and first of all I've
already you've got to figure out what
the new paradigm is and then the next
step is you've got to figure out what we
call the jujitsu so we the entrepreneurs
or either individually or collectively
are always a really small force so how
do we change the whole assistant way
people think so
did you just sue what you have to do is
figure out what are the smallest number
of forces that you need to set in motion
with one another to create a chemical
reaction that becomes a self multiplying
force and then draws in others so we're
really small we can't deal with a lot
but if we choose the minimum number so
here's what we think we need to do for
the US and this is underway and underway
right here in this part of the country
so we started this a year and a half ago
we think 60 schools out of 80,000 30
writers and publishers and a team of
Ashoka fellows who are Co leading the
effort so all we have to deal with is
ninety one team
to how the triggering effect take place
we can do that right so 160 schools well
first of all there are five in the Bay
Area you will not be surprised to
discover you're ahead of the curve and
that's what living in an epicenter means
so we're looking for schools and please
help us we're looking we've got 13 of
the 16 hour we're inviting others to
come in for the second thirty who
represent all the diversity of types of
kids types of school types of community
who have a track record of causing
change so once they're on fire and they
really want to do this they're good at
it you don't choose a basketball team
short people who don't know how to play
basketball I
and then third there's got to be a team
of people in each of those schools who
totally understands everyone a change
maker this is where the world is going
this is a fact they understand that and
therefore they know that every child
must master cognitive empathy must not
this is a nice thing and it's sort of
Buddhists and all that this is
completely critical and it's not one of
sixteen things this is something that we
have to do and they know that if they
figure out how to do that they're doing
something really important for their
kids their school their community the
country and beyond
they're on a big playing field so this
is us recruiting our team of teams so 60
schools 30 writers and publishers and
the team of fellows so take Univision
they serve the Hispanic community they
don't have a story until we have
Hispanic schools that are on fire you
put those two together both of them can
really have a big impact if we get five
or six major writers and publishers
going on this in the schools pushing in
it we've got 12 Ashoka fellows who are
actively leading two of them from this
area parenthetically one of them at
Stanford and
you begin to see what's going to happen
parents begin to catch on and they ask
schools well how good is your school
dear principal and empathy and some
principals say we're very good come here
and tipping process is underway now
we're a year and a half into this and
two frankly my great surprise we have
three graduate schools of Education who
see this is on their critical path they
really want to do this because when
suddenly 10,000 or 30,000 schools want
to do it they're going to be
well-positioned to serve and that's not
going to hurt them that wouldn't be
happening if we're not close to the
tipping point there's another five end
schools who want in so you this begins
to affect more you've got a very
positive dynamic that is the tipping
process so I this is very short but
collaborative entrepreneurship once you
understand how to cause pattern change
triggering sorry framework change
triggering pattern and direct service
change right so the last part this is
very personal this is a moment in
history these changes affect all of us
in every part of our lives so are you
developing the skills you need
have you given yourself permission to be
a change maker or a entrepreneur for the
good of all which is what a social
entrepreneur is how are you helping your
friends make that journey everyone here
knows and cares about some young person
well if you've got a 15 year old and she
says to you or 12 year old this is a
mess put down whatever you're doing and
say to her well why don't you get your
friends together and fix it
who me yeah you can do this that
conversation is incredibly important and
then you have to learn how to be
supportive without taking over the whole
adult young person relationship is
adults in charge you know you are
incompetent irresponsible stay out of
the way we do it fester or apply to
version Deary let me do that for you all
of us can do this now I on this this is
so important I talked about young
children for a moment let me just share
with you a story that really had a big
impact on me I bet the shoka youth bench
your program that is designed for any
young person who has their own dream
builds a team it wants to change it the
goal is to change the youth culture in
every middle in high school so that it
is and everyone a change maker culture
and every kid is encouraged to do this
so this is a really poor rural area
Appalachian in its basic culture and
that this young woman I'm about to
describe comes from so we're not talking
about middle-class privileged kids here
we have a couple of hundred of these of
shoking youth ventures I'm sitting down
at lunch she comes over I can just feel
her power before she sits down and she
very quickly lets us know she's 12
does she look smaller than that and okay
what did you do well my younger brother
is autistic and I have hated the way
kids treat him Oh what did you do so she
has a system that she and her team spot
a case like this and they figure out how
to go and deal with it the psychology of
that case at the same time they have an
awareness program for the whole school
now I guarantee you if any of you had
the experience I did you would not have
the slightest doubt for one millisecond
that she is going to be a change maker
all her life because she already is she
has her power she has her graduate
degree she's not going to be afraid of
anything in her life she knows how to
work with people she's already put
together a team and she'll just keep
doing it
now there's one more part of the story
this is why this story I find
particularly compelling I asked her next
how many student groups are there in
your middle school Oh over 50 well how
many middle schools do you now have over
50 student groups that so when she
walked into that school
she had this problem and the youth
culture said to her you got a problem
you solve it you build a team look we've
got 50 teams here you can do it too and
we'll help you we'll be with you now
that's what we need in every middle and
high school in the country and here and
around the world how on earth are we
going to have a generation of
changemakers if we don't have a
generation of changemakers in middle and
high school you can't learn this by a
book you have to actually do it and it
how do you live in a world where
everyone is a change maker if you're
still living in a 19th or 18th century
culture of the classroom and please
write so everyone here can contribute to
this we all know young people and care
about them if you've got a six-year-old
and she hits her four-year-old brother
or a put her arm around her and say how
do you think your little brother felt
when you did that I had that question
yes to me a lot when I was growing up
and I am now grateful for it so we all
can do this we are also all in
institutions and we care about some of
them probably everyone here cares about
this university you're going to care
about a citizen group or a company or a
religious group or sporting club can you
help that group make this transition
virtually every group has to make the
transition it's not easy well that's
another challenge for everyone here and
then finally this is one of those rare
moments in history where we are
privileged all of us if we give
ourselves permission to really
contribute to this history everyone here
can help
this change happened it's a matter of
helping people open up their minds to
see ok we're living in a world of change
this is the new game this is a much much
better game everyone a change maker
means there's no way the problems outrun
the solutions it's an inherently far
more equal society because everyone is
really powerful everyone a change maker
think about that and then everyone has
this experience we all do if being able
to express love and respect in action
and have a really happy life really
happy so thank you wow that was
inspiring and I am going to be a change
maker right now because what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna change up the schedule
and I'm going to open up to questions as
well ok powerful was your model of the
three levels of engagement sort of
direct service pattern change and
framework change now do people make a
decision at what level they want to
engage or is it something you need to
start out at the bottom you know first I
need to be sort of an individual
contributor and start using my empathy
to identify opportunities and move up
this hierarchy or can you just come
right in at the top and change the
framework well there are many social
entrepreneurs in the world who have done
just that they came up in a world that
this was very foreign you just try being
a social entrepreneur in 1981 in
Indonesia you know that Javanese culture
is no you don't upset anybody that's the
last thing you do so and there's no word
to describe the field but yet the social
entrepreneurs were there bringing about
really fundamental change so yes people
can do this the examples I gave you Mary
Gordon and her classroom she gave
herself permission no one told her to do
this
and the concept of that we've been
talking about here she didn't have that
concept
she was solving that specific problems
when she came into the community of
Ashoka fellows and our joint learning
that she was able to see the larger
pattern Joe Violette was about the right
to play well suddenly she realized that
group play was a really good way for
kids to master empathy and avoid
marginalization and much better future
for their kids the school the community
the country well suddenly she has five
new six new arguments for why her work
is important so there anyone can take
the initiative but it is much harder
before the society is tipped and if you
just take a high school or middle school
the first one two three four kids you do
this I've got to change the youth
culture in that school that is hard it's
a youth culture of incompetence and lack
of confidence and a certain amount of
anger and resentment which is not very
functional and so helping the first kids
who do this so that when this young
woman I was describing comes in it's the
norm
once it's the norm it's much easier and
once it's the norm and all the parts of
society flow one into the other
elementary school through work they're
all structured this way and people value
these values and we're constantly trying
to help one another develop them loud
fine thanks Philip doctor was very
interesting I was curious you talked a
lot about education
I was curious as to what you think the
best motivators are for young people say
in high school 17 18 who haven't been
introduced to this cause it's not only
empathy but also having been introduced
to to new technologies and having
developed that curiosity to be
game-changers what do you think is the
best the starting point biggest
motivators that you can give them to try
and make them understand you know this
is good for you you should spend your
time doing it in the context of that
high school
it's a classmate who's doing it and you
know once you get four or five kids who
are succeeding - in the first year three
in the second year you have a hundred
kids who are saying come and join us
this is really important and you can tip
the culture of the school at that point
now society-wide
it's really important for us all to work
together so that we all see this so
parents see it the principal's see it
the other kids see it I when you get to
the tipping point it goes really really
quickly and we're very close at the
moment we've studied the civil rights
movement the women's movement several
Gandhian movements in use you see the
same pattern a few organizations push
and push and push we begin to get
islands who start doing this Silicon
Valley is a very big one of the most
sophisticated I and they start
connecting with one another I think the
web for example and suddenly you get to
the point where large numbers of people
are less afraid of hearing this because
people might laugh at them and more
afraid that if they don't listen and
participate they're going to be not in
the conversation and their daughter
might be hurt or their organization and
we're right at that tipping point once
you get there things go really quickly
and you know once young people have
figured out which isn't going to be hard
that this is the game you got to play if
you want to be powerful well I can just
tell you young people really hate being
treated is the last large colonial
population in the world
there's been a whole series of marketing
studies by companies and others this
right up there with the hormonal
interests they really hate it but it's
inarticulate once we articulate it and
you have the models they'll go really
quickly so you talk about breaking down
walls and that sounds really great but
how do you actually know that a wall is
there you'll often ruin organizations
and where people are so used to them
they don't even see them anymore so how
do you actually notice them all is there
and then start breaking it down well our
goal for this part of the work is in
fact five years six years from now that
anyone doing strategy whether it's
business school or engineering school or
McKinsey my old firm I'm just talking to
the managing partner about this two
weeks ago or someone running a religious
ounce we want anyone who thinks about
strategy to know that if they look
around them and they see a wall business
social whatever it is they very very
probably have a huge productivity
breakthrough opportunity wealth service
opportunity if they know how to put
people together that we're not working
together before the new hybrid
production productivity systems and that
becomes in a world of a world of fluid
open teams of teams that are constantly
changing that becomes completely
essential skill so we think of it sort
of three different phrases walls no more
that's sort of when you see a wall you
know you have that opportunity then
hybrid value systems that's the critical
leadership skill you've got to have in
this new world it's one of the central
ones and you end up the end result is a
fluid open team of teams so this is
another perfect example of a frame
or change now we have actually
demonstrated this because we figured
people wouldn't listen to us unless we
did in several different environments
then because of time I know you're
looking at me I will I will be very
brief about this so in India there are
twenty four point eight missing housing
units for informal sector workers in the
cities the informal sector worker means
you buy vegetables for example in the
morning you sell all day you make a
profit supports your family all right so
why are there always missing housing
units well there is a complete market
failure from the point of view of
business the vegetable seller doesn't
get a pay stub there's no paperwork well
how the hell do you deal with that and
they want it they need and can afford a
200 to 280 square foot home well that's
a little bit different from what we make
now and who are they what they belong to
what group and they they live where so
complete market failure on the other
side you have a large citizen sector
that has come up that's actually very
competent and has a much lower cost
structure that lives in these
neighborhoods has trust but they're
lousy at real estate development and
they don't have access to mortgage
capital so market failure now here we
are you see a big wall that is
separating these people it's obvious
what the answer is once you get this new
framework in your head you all know
right now
so you ask the citizen groups to do the
things that have to deal with the
neighborhood's the marketing the
judgments about lending the technical
assistance all the way through to
collection and you payment for that this
is a major new source of income for the
citizen sector that will only grow the
builders build the finance people
finance right so what has happened in
omnibus is the first city where at least
got this underway about seven months ago
I'm little bit late on statistics there
were four thousand seven hundred units
that were either built and occupied or
almost another twenty five thousand that
were at the stage at least of land
option ten of the cities have taken this
up eight new finance firms have come
into a market that didn't exist two
years ago and we've got two major global
financial institutions are looking at
this as a really big opportunity you
know if you translate from those few
cases to the twenty four point eight
million this is a three hundred and
forty billion dollar market failure that
is now being fixed and that's before you
think of the 700 million other Indians
that are likely to move into the cities
and it's before you think about the
three hundred square foot house since
before you think about China or etc etc
this was all it required is starting to
think this way look for a wall and if
you can figure out you just can't ask
people to keep doing what they were
doing before and put them in a room
you've got to figure out a new system
and that requires being a good
entrepreneur so there's a for example
right now in that case we don't want to
keep putting these things together oh so
how are we going to solve that well so
we think we need the equivalent of the
real estate agent doing co-opting or
condominium Ising buildings here so for
1% of the deal there's a new class of
people that are in the process coming up
in three cities so far housing for all
entrepreneurs well the business people
like this because this is less expensive
than they had to pay they used to pay
two or three percent from the point of
view of these people if you do 500 units
that's $100,000
well even taking off your costs you know
this begins to look very attractive in
the Indian context but the point is not
housing the point is this is we want
everyone to think in this new metal
framework so you are the guy
father of social entrepreneurship but I
haven't heard you use that term today
which is very interesting what do you
think of the future of social
entrepreneurship do you when we talked
beforehand you said that you actually
sort of saw that as something that was
an incredibly important term and and
processed before do you see that as
really critical going forward and how
does social entrepreneurship relate to
traditional entrepreneurship that we
teach in our classes all right so
there's just a historical oddity that
happened and when we can understand why
but around 1700 business broke out into
the everyone a changemaker world
structurally this is an incredibly
radical breakthrough he said have you
got a better idea and you implement it
we're gonna make you rich and respected
and we're going to copy you that was the
beginning of the end of the elites and
from Rome to 1700 there was no growth in
per capita income in the West it went up
and down with weather cycles in the
1700s it went up 20% in the 1800s 200
percent in the last century 740 percent
of course this revolution has been going
out across the world but it didn't
happen for either government or the
citizen sector why I think the main
reason is that it was so easy for
government to tax the new wealth I
you're not taking away something from
people they had before so they barely
notice it so government grew and paid
for the citizen sector and government
doesn't have to be a monopoly but it
just is it's just part of part of it
being historic and not modern and no
monopoly can stand competition so the
paymaster said don't compete and so the
citizen sector this is weird fell behind
for three centuries from business and so
we ended up with a real difference
business developed business schools and
language and all this stuff and we
didn't we it's really hard to remember
what the citizen sector was like 30
years ago he was so demoralized no one
would go into
and it was it was sad and we started
ashoka in 1980 because we've believed
that that was going to break out and it
did and so over the last thirty years
there has been a dramatic increase in
the productivity and scale and now
globalization of the sector and so we've
been growing jobs at two-and-a-half
three times the rate of the rest of the
OECD economy as we catch up now and
that's one of the reasons it's such an
exciting sector it is growing much
faster in terms of productivity as well
as just simple growth and
parenthetically that growth and
employment is mirrored by the growth in
the the volunteer part of the sector so
it's not a transfer of one to the other
both are growing so the what that says
is as in the example I just gave you
that barrier is going to fall and
everyone here can contribute to that but
there is you know there's a second and
more modern definition of social
entrepreneurship that is actually
becoming more important and so let me
explain that first of all the word
entrepreneur entrepreneur means pattern
change it does not mean direct service
so that means a still a relatively small
number of people and social means that
from deep within that person is
committed to the good of all and
therefore their work is now I have said
nothing nothing what I've just said
defines sector every type of person is
in education businesses governments
religion as people of us or that
ideology and people who care about the
good of all and as we go especially as
we go through this transition is and we
enter a world that everything is bumping
everything faster and faster all the
systems we used to assume we're steady
or not steady
they're bumping one another just as much
as anything else well it's very
very important to have a group of
entrepreneurs on the playing field who
are constantly pulling the game back to
the center because there are lots of
entrepreneurs there who are there for
self-interest or the shareholders
interest or some religious or
ideological point of view and it's not
that they intend to do evil just that
they accidentally do so I'll use a very
concrete example I'm privacy we are
losing privacy really fast and I think
privacy is really important for freedom
and creativity why are we losing it well
first of all we need preventive
surveillance because a few people can do
a lot of damage with the technology we
have today I don't see how we avoid that
second you all know about Moore's Law it
all invented here well that means you
can connect all the dots for almost
nothing and more and more people can do
that and that's not good for privacy and
then third the dominant business model
in the digital realm is you give people
something they want you get information
and you sell it now our friends at
Google and we really have enormous
respect for them they are caught in that
system they are not helping privacy now
you need the social entrepreneurs who
are really focused on the good of all
who will notice a trend like this and
for just because inside them they have
this commitment to the good of all they
are going to step up and you can see
that happening you can see the antidotes
of the social entrepreneurs beginning to
deal with this problem of our loss of
privacy so I hope and I expect actually
but who knows for sure but I expect we
are moving to a world where everyone is
going to be driven by empathy based
ethics and that will be the norm but we
are still in this unhappy transition
period where the dominant systems are
rules and enforcement and fear which
works less and less well because it's
too complicated too many moving
pieces and so corruption is getting
worse not no surprise they were not
quite there where everyone in every
institution is being encouraged and
helped to live a life that is guided by
empathy based ethics we probably have to
change some of the goals and measures of
success to do that for example thank you
very much another question how you
balance compassion with what you think
the world needs most and what happens
when the two are at odds the question is
how do you balance your own personal
passions with what the world needs most
hey I find it really hard to imagine
that there would be a conflict if you
are really being guided by empathy based
ethics and I you know I said the most
important thing for personal happiness
is being able to give in a significant
way the biggest gift you can give anyone
is giving them the gift that they can
give and of course we all have different
passions my college roommate was and is
an artist and you know he's not an
entrepreneur and he is just one of the
loveliest people I know he's you know so
he does he has a life of direct service
in that field that's not in conflict we
need really dedicated teachers in a
classroom they are going to have to be
changed makers - charlie my roommate has
to be a change maker the art look at how
art is changing
look at I mean we've just been talking
about the revolution it's coming to all
teachers so I am puzzled maybe you could
expand on what the conflict is because
I'm maybe missing something here I guess
it's there there are many different
types of issues and it's tempting to
order them by what is the most needed or
what we need it and when you have a
variety of passions it's hard to choose
when you're being selfish or when you're
trying to be more effective because
maybe this issue isn't something that's
as needed based on research or whatever
it is but it's something that I can do
more effective at because I'm more
passionate out so this is very personal
I just think you should do what you
really love as long as it fits with
helping other people in the best way you
can
Charlie loves being an artist and he is
incredibly good at it
he has worked out a role of designing
parks so he has some income coming in
you know I think he's living a wonderful
life and the saddest thing I can see and
I see it a lot and my law school
classmates got stuck in the system many
of them and I can see them squishing who
they really were
and they're not happy about it but
they're caught they think and that's
really really sad that's not doing
anyone any good I lasted in want for
seven weeks thank God it was over
quickly and you know if it doesn't fit
who you are for God's sakes run what it
is to be an engineer in the future you
know if you are a change major change
maker in a high-tech company as an
engineer what would that look like well
I hope that all of us learn to
understand all of society this whole
stovepiping thing I am only a lawyer
only an engineer only a baker that's
part of the old world it's really
important that everybody understand the
whole of society what's the fun of being
in a little box now of course you bring
special talents and skills to bear but
you know Darlene who we'd see Ashoka
effort here in the Bay Area and I were
just over at singularity University this
morning and the challenge that they have
was how do we marry so that the best
technology I is they would like to
figure out how to serve the sort of
changes we're talking about here well we
need that sort of technology the rate at
which repetition is being driven out is
very heavily technology-based AI the
algorithm the web is just you know
repetition is going away much faster
than agriculture did nineteen hundred
almost all everyone in this country
ninety seven percent were in agriculture
were now at two and three percent
repetition is going that way I just
might I have two recent stories that I
loved about this I was talking to the
guy who runs McKinsey and he told me he
used to run the China work he told me
about Ali Baba's new lending operation
well the seizing of billions of dollars
is huge a dollar to ten thousand dollar
loans well how many people and parenting
they have much better metrics than any
of the other banks in China not that
they're a bank now how many people do
you think is running that these are vast
numbers of small loans all over the
country what do you think they're
staffing is all right well I I will
spare you embarrassment that I suffered
them I'd have to answer this it's 200
well how many millions of bank people
are going out the window
in terms of repetitive functions and
these are intellectual repetitive
functions not physical automation that's
going out the window my other great
story is this was in The New Yorker
about three or four or five weeks ago
archaeologists you know they go into the
jungle and if they didn't look to their
right and look through two feet and
foilage they'd miss a wall that was
there and they had to deal with snakes
and insects and all this
stuff very slow uncertain process so
lidar probably invented by someone
around here not an archaeologist but a
New York explorer allied to what else uh
Beverly Hills movie guy got together to
go down to the mountains on the western
part facing the Gulf of Mexico with
Central America which got a lot of rain
and snakes and all this stuff had there
been golden Cities keep people talking
about that so they said we're not gonna
go with all those snakes and they got
permission they rented this little plane
they made a hole in the bottom of the
slide our machine sends billions of
light rays down and captures them
bouncing up and because of the great
computer science people here they can
tell if it's bouncing from a leaf or a
stone so all the vegetation goes away
the plane flies back and forth over this
Manhattan sized valley for three days
like a 1960s fax machine and guess what
they discovered the whole valley is a
city the whole valley streets aqueducts
building and they have it all there no
that's does away with 85% of what
archeologists do in terms of field work
now I so you know you know what cad/cam
did it took away 40% of what architects
do the Watson technology at IBM IBM
thinks it'll get rid of 50 to 59 percent
of what doctors and nurses do so
repetition is really really going away
and which is great who wants to do
repetition if you can be a change maker
but then people really have to get into
this new thing and so I just think this
is a completely wonderful time we're
going into but everyone here is going to
have a great time at this
but we also have a trust we have the
privilege of being able to see this and
now there's a challenge of how do we
help the society see it and articulate
it so please do
you